this is the ingram angle from washington
tonight an alarming exchange in the
house of representatives today revealed
the true intention of democrats when it
comes to your firearms we're going to go
back and show you this back and forth
and speak to the republican who elicited
this admission but first the real
military destroyers that's the focus of
tonight's angle
let's face it the left is really good at
destroying things they destroyed
education during the pandemic with all
those school closures
they've destroyed respect for law
enforcement we see that all the time
they've destroyed historical markers
ripped down statues
they destroyed entire city blocks to
honor george floyd they destroyed
independent medical practices with
obamacare
they destroyed free speech on college
campuses
and they're hoping to destroy the
electoral college the filibuster
the u.s senate and if we let them the
constitution itself
so basically anything that holds
traditional american ideals has to be
destroyed
and now it looks like they're on the
path to destroy our all-volunteer
military
and as the media obsess on the fake
climate change crisis they're glossing
over a real crisis
the gradual depletion of our military
fighting force
and as a result most americans don't
have a clue about how dire the situation
is
so how bad is it
well the army is right now short of its
60 thousand soldier recruiting goal for
the fiscal year by half that's 30 000
soldier deficit
and for next year it's expected to be
even worse
don't forget the army had already
reduced its annual recruiting target by
5 000 because of an earlier shortfall
and yes we've known for months the
problem is occurring across all military
branches
this is a complete disaster and the
white house and congress should be
working 24 7 to address this
instead they spend their days talking
about wind power and january 6th
where's the warhawk liz cheney on all
this
well late today the army issued a
five-page memo that tried to explain why
this is happening
claiming they're in a war for talent and
are in the most challenging recruiting
environment since 1973.
recruiting motivated fit and
academically proficient men and women
continues to be a challenge
only 23 percent of military-aged men and
women in the united states are qualified
to serve
now read between the lines people
he seems to be saying that our potential
pool of recruits is too fat too stupid
and too unmotivated but that's not all
we've got unprecedented challenges
with both a post covid 19 environment
and labor market but also competition
private competition with private
companies that have changed their
incentives over time
okay this is absurd did we not have a
free market for labor competition
before the last few years
and as for the post coven 19 environment
reference
the general should really have been more
blunt
the vaccine mandate is definitely a
factor here
this may get even worse because the u.s
net army national guard and army reserve
are facing the prospect that some 60 000
of their force
may not be willing to get the covet
vaccine and if they don't get the covet
vaccine they will not be able to be part
of the active force they will not be
able to be activated and go on missions
i mean at least cnn did the report i
gave him kudos for that but what a
nightmare
but they had to know that this would
happen the military did and they did it
anyway
of course don't press general milly or
secretary austin about any of this
because
they're more worried about propping up
the ukrainian military than fixing ours
we're going to keep moving at the speed
of war
we're going to make clear that mike does
not make right
we're going to stand strong with our
fellow contact group members
and we're going to support ukraine's
self-defense for the long haul
and we're going to defend the
rules-based international order
that protects us all okay there's so
much to unpack there but the speed of
war
now they're the same people who thought
that the afghan army could hold out for
a year but of course it collapsed in
just a few weeks
their advice and analysis is
consistently wrong
and under their leadership the russians
don't fear us putin's grinding right
through ukraine and the chinese don't
fear us
they're even threatening us over
pelosi's potential trip to taiwan
and meanwhile young americans aren't
inspired by them
so i hate to break it to the generals
but our troops don't sign up to fight
for their idiotic rules-based
international order
which only basically helps china big
business and the globalists
and has this international order that
general austin was just referencing
protecting us from fentanyl or border
crime or the closing of our factories or
the outsourcing of our jobs
has to stop china from building as many
coal plants as a damwell pleases
of course not
this is a problem with our senior
leaders our senior leaders inability to
have a courage their hypocrisy it's
affecting all other things our senior
military leaders have demonstrated
through action that we can't trust them
and you would be naive to think that a
young american isn't getting online
going on the internet and seeing all the
missteps that we can clearly see of our
senior military leaders
well the fact of the matter is in large
part our military is suffering a severe
recruitment crisis because our military
leadership is more focused on being woke
in following dr fauci than winning wars
and liberals in the house they're
totally fine with this not surprising in
fact they want to make the military even
more radical
we can and must do better to ensure that
we continue to provide this world-class
training to our female military leaders
around the world this amendment would
simply require a gender analysis
assessment of the program by signaling
the importance of including more gender
diversity in the program this is not
just important it's smart
now how worried do you think china and
russia are about their lack of a gender
analysis and their military training
this is just embarrassing
now we see the stark change in our
military identity don't we and the type
of recruitment videos they're producing
these days now during reagan and the 80s
the videos look like this
you're reaching deep inside you know
things you've never known
it's been tough rough going but you're
having on alone
we do more before 9 a.m than most people
do all day
[Music]
hey first sergeant
good
[Music]
don't you want to go back to the 80s
unabashedly patriotic totally cool
well this is how they recruit today
this is the story of a soldier who
operates your nation's patriot missile
defense systems
it begins in california
with a little girl raised by two moms
literally
they're using cartoons
why is having two mommies relevant at
all the answer is it's not
so that would definitely get an a as
like a woman studies project but it
fails in the recruiting soldiers
department
the fact is our military leadership has
just rolled over for the most radical
left-wing ideas out there
and within our military including at our
military academies they're actively
teaching crt and actively promoting the
trans and sexual identity agenda
after speaking with several military
sources from enlisted men to recent
grads of ocs the angle believes that
this recruitment crisis
is a self-inflicted wound by the
workstars and at some point you do have
to wonder
if this is their goal
just as it's their goal to force you to
suffer economic pain for their
transition
to clean energy
is it their goal to destroy our
all-volunteer force in order to pave the
way for a smaller global force
it's 2022 we face an aggressive
adversary in communist china
and our standing army is contracting as
theirs is growing
in fact it's far larger than ours is now
from putin's merciless rampage across
ukraine to china's menacing actions near
taiwan we already see the balance of
power beginning to tip away from the u.s
but under biden and the woke military
leadership our enemies are getting
bolder and bolder by the day
now the entire time that trump was in
office the military kept putting up
roadblocks to the changes that he wanted
to make including the withdrawal from
afghanistan by the way
the pentagon in all its arrogance
resisted president trump every step of
the way
this is how much power they have they're
almost a government unto their own
gop members of congress have a moral
obligation right now
to hold hearings carry out
investigations and demand real reform
we love our enlisted troops and we
cherish their heroic sacrifices they
don't deserve this
congress should not just keep shoveling
money out the door regardless of the
results
but that's exactly what they're doing
biden asked for 802 billion dollars for
the next year defense budget
the the house ended up voting to round
it up to a cool 800 839 billion dollars
unreal
america is quickly moving from a
position when we ask
what should we do in international
affairs to one where we ask can we do
anything when the american taxpayers
have spent trillions of dollars in our
military and lost thousands and
thousands of brave and selfless troops
we have a right and we have a duty to
require accountability across the board
it's bad enough that americans have lost
faith in our public schools and our
public health sector and our government
in general but if americans lose faith
in our military
we will be facing a grave national
security threat
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else